I like all this emotional talk dude I do
I watched some of your guys's stuff and
I think to myself I wish these guys were
more emotional yeah I want to hear the
real side of things sometimes sure I
like when people break down and they get
a little a little real yeah let's get
real then
what am I trying to get real about yeah
this is a new segment what are you
trying to get real about that's an
interesting segment also I like how did
you just put that up the Hogwarts screen
cap yeah Luke is very good at this now
like he's so good at just uh using the
screen to punch jokes and like [__] on
us almost sometimes it's very funny
well like for example anytime me and
Cody get a little too cocky he just
pulls up the Walkman lyrics and we go
all right Luke how about you [__] off
with that that was like one of the first
things I ever said to you yeah that was
yeah you're talking about Sophia Sophia
all right because I like that yeah I
started singing it and he was like stop
it yeah I was like okay yeah walk man
how does that go hey there's a Sophia
deal there look at that just just say
some of the lyrics off that
um just read it
also when did this song even come out is
this a new song no this is old okay yeah
dude I'm sorry I don't know it's [__]
discography
of Walkman
shorty jumping in the front row got her
face on my wood like a totem pole God
damn
that's good yeah
um was it
uh mile is low from the blunt smoke
feeling r b holding Blue Notes uh that
line actually is something that many
people say what the [__] did you mean by
that boy you only busted down with a
[__] bus pass [__] yeah
okay huh here's this one's for Ray
Liotta smacking your girlie's box she's
a camel pack
she's a Chantix she's a Chantix that's
the updated one yeah chewing your girl's
back she's a chain takes enjoy the
girl's box like it's a package Antics
gum available to every Walgreens
just turns into an advert immediately
then Dan that'd be so good man imagine
that though dude Ray Liotta going down
on you chewing on your Chantix piece
yeah like a piece of gum going at it
like a Fruit Stripe gum the flavor I've
lost the flavor already that's true what
they say I just felt half the Earth go
dry when you said that
dry it up dude yeah
yeah I have one song on the internet do
you actually I do I've never told
anybody I'm not gonna tell you guys all
right Luke do your thing all right Luke
do your thing but it's it's on there and
it's me as a medal of vocalist when I
was 19. hmm and it exists it's out there
wow
Luke I'm working on it yeah I'm working
on CSI Jarvis
do your thing can we get uh Hunter
singing at 19 please you're not a lot of
people compliment me last time of my
journey singing yeah no you got a great
voice I do
I I would be a liar if I said stood here
and sat here and said
where am I
like I feel like I just had a stroke
I'm actually turning into Porky Pig
which is the worst part of my life yeah
it's the worst thing ever
dude I thought you're gonna get real
with me I don't really know what to get
real about I feel like I'm a very
transparent person you are what would
you like I told you last night that uh
about the yeah yeah yeah yeah that was
super transparent of you I think so yeah
should we do you want to relive that for
the viewers yeah well all right we're
having a discussion about Korean
barbecue yeah over Korean barbecue right
uh we were talking about
we as a young male your first
experiences with your own
come
and Hunter described to us
he he casually says you know you've
nutted in your hand before and you've
like
you know every guy and this is a true
thing doesn't matter if people are gonna
be like no [__] every guy has done
that thing where you know like the
Scholastic Book Fair this isn't
correlate at the Scholastic Book Fair
where you'd get like those little tubes
of like slime and you're like whoa this
is crazy every guy has done that with
the oyster in their hand with his web
yes yeah and you sit there and you play
with it and that's whenever I thought to
myself that's whenever I found that I
didn't I stopped believing in God that
day do you know why
because I sat there when I was playing
with it I did the most chimp-like thing
I've ever done in my life where
stringing out in a very fascinated and
then I bit my hand down I did
when I looked around like that and I
smelt it and it was but it was that look
around I was like that was the closest
I've ever been
to being an ape yeah and I was like that
proves Evolution right there I thought
that was an interesting point in life
for you to be become atheist [__] you
yeah just holding your [__] actually I
don't believe you know you're coming
yeah just like my soupy coming my hand
ball of nut and you're like there's no
way you're real I doubt it
I doubt this
yeah every every guy is gonna be like
yeah definitely because I think every
guy smelt it and then some people have
tasted it I've not tasted it yeah I've
refused to taste my own make yeah as
they say Ryan have you ever tasted it no
I've heard some insane now I'm just
recalling insane stories bro oh wow oh
what wow oh wow what is this even from a
live stream you did
all right well we don't have to play
that
it's me just it's just me working on a
Scooby-Doo cartoon dude it's nothing to
see
19 years young though I played a lot of
shows in Kansas City did you actually
old the only places you could get like
metal shows when you're starting off
with like old strip clubs no so strip
clubs on weekends would or on weekends
on like Thursdays and Tuesdays yeah you
could play shows there there wasn't like
a
um
what do they call them
what's the [__] like an American
Legion type venue yeah I got VFW yeah
yeah I mean there probably was but the
only ones we ever got was strip clubs
got it I just know that uh VFW places
are like that's where I did a lot of my
early musical performances and I felt
really yeah American Legions always seem
to be very welcoming too
young kids making music that's nice yeah
I need to go support the veterans at the
American Legion I don't think we were
supporting the veterans because they
charged us literally next to no money
didn't put on the show so
yeah let's uh let's shall we have a
listen no we really shouldn't because
also this is from a live thing so it's
like this isn't the probably the best
product to show be vulnerable huh come
on be vulnerable okay dude you get real
with them easy back there bro people
tell me it's like my ghost is dummy to
be vulnerable
be vulnerable hey I'm you know I'm over
here telling you that uh
I I get insecure around you at times and
you don't even play us your [__]
metal song
no
all right fair fair fair
I hear you though on actually this I'm
jumping back a point but I hear you on
no I mean I heard you on Ray Liotta we
definitely heard you for 20 minutes on
Ray Liotta I don't want to say don't
don't say we heard you this was a
combined effort of talking about rayleo
I think we could do percentages okay
we mostly heard you on Ray Liotta okay
all right dude what whatever
I could talk about I wish I just had a
rayleota podcast I would talk about
Rayleigh out all [__] day okay good
okay I would the Rayleigh yeah because
he's done enough films that you could
actually make one he's done films yeah